Out of four choices,
which one did you pick, David?
>> So, I picked the first one, but
I think there's actually
two correct answers.
What we're looking for
is something else in S1 that has
a negation in another sentence.
Not has wings has a negation in S2,
so we could resolve on S2 with
the not has wings portion of S1.
Has fur also has a negation in S3.
So we could also resolve on S3 and
the has fur portion of S1.
>> This is right, David.
At the end of this, we're left with
null, which is a contradiction.
Therefore, an assumption
that is not bird is false.
Therefore, it must be a bird and
the robot has just proved
that this must be a bird.
Note what we have done.
We have mechanized parts of logic.
And sort of coming up
with large truth tables.
And it's sort of coming up with
complex chains of inference
based on modus ponens and modus tollens.
We have found in our garden
resolutions are improving,
which is a efficient way of proving
sentences and the truth values.
This is how it works.
Take all the sentence and
the knowledge base,
convert them into conjecture novel form.
Take what you want to prove and
its negation.
Put that as a new sentence.
Now, starting with this particular
sentence, a new sentence.
Find the literal in another sentence
on which you can resolve, and
keep on doing it until you find a null
condition, which is a contradiction.
If you don't find a null condition,
if you don't find a contradiction,
that means that what you
started with cannot be proved.